hello
and thank you for joining us for today's
presentation
part of our agilent cell analysis global
conference
my name is justine ho i'm the west coast
food application scientist in the cell
analysis division at angelin and i will
be your host for today
before i introduce our speaker for today
allow me to share a bit about
agilent and our products for cell
analysis
agilent as a leader in life science is
very focused on enabling our customers
to gain insights they seek a rapidly
growing cell analysis portfolio
enables deeper more reliable insights
for investigators to gain confidence in
their interpretation through
all stages of development such as in
drug
target and identification and validation
drug efficacy
mechanism of action toxicity safety and
translational
research this is critically important to
open new avenues
of therapeutic intervention and expand
drug discovery pipeline
a presentation today will speak
specifically on how agilent's technology
are being employed in drug discovery
it is my pleasure to introduce today's
speaker who i've gotten to know
for many years dr joy fenn principal
scientist
from gilead science joy will present on
the mechanism based off
target screening the risk clinical
development
of antiviral nucleoside and nucleotides
drugs this is important research to
advance our understanding
of therapeutics and antiviral drug
development especially under this curtin
global pandemic
joyfun is a principal scientist at
gilead science
she has a phd in medicinal chemistry
from the university of florida
during her post-doc training at dr
karen's anderson slab at yale
joy developed her deep appreciation of
mitochondria
while studying drug induced mitochondria
toxicity
using an enzymatic approach at gilead
joy continues to probe drug-induced
mitochondria toxicity in addition to
studying mitochondria enzyme she also
used mitochondria protein
cellular respiration and other
parameters to evaluate
mitochondria toxicity she has used
these approaches successfully to access
mitochondrial liability
for multiple approved antiviral agents
for hiv
hcv and most recently covet 19.
but before i head it over to joy i would
like to go over a couple of housekeeping
notes there will be a question and
answer session immediately following our
talk
to help us get through as many questions
as possible
we encourage you to type the question in
during
the presentation right after the
presentation
we invite you to join myself and joy
and other experts in the networking
lounge for further discussion
we also would like you to invite you to
stop at the postal session if you
haven't done so and visit
some of our experts in the exhibit hall
to learn more about what's new at
agilent
with that i will hand the presentation
over to dr
joy fenn joy
then and it's always lovely to have
your friend to open a lecture for you
and today i want to bring everyone to
the world of antiviral drug discovery
and share the painful lessons we have
learned in the past 40 years
and when i say we actually i mean the
broader sense the collective of us
uh not that including the scientists who
discover these drugs
and the the clinicians bring them to
phase
one to clinical trial and also the
patients
so with this um let me go to what i'd
like to cover for today
is um the nucleosides analogues
if you haven't heard of this term before
welcome
um the topic of the cover is what are
they why they work so well as antivirals
actually they are the cornerstones of so
many therapies we use to
treat multiple viral infections and what
are the
earth fact we see in clinical trials
and why will come to you why
mitochondria are actually one of the off
targets
and the the fourth point is why it's
important
to distinguish this mitochondria
specific toxicity
away from the general toxicity
and what we learned after all these
years
can we screen also see this closest
early on even before they enter
the the preclinical animal species
and the last ram deserve to tie into
today's climate
is how do we evaluate ram desperately in
the screening paradigm i'll show you in
a minute
so now let's i'm going to share with you
what are the nucleotides that are
analogs
so before we go through the analogs let
me share with you what are the natural
ones
so what i'm showing you here um are the
structures of
on the left is the deoxycytotin
on the right is ribocytin and the only
difference is basically the hydroxyl
group
on the two prime of the ribose
and they are the building blocks of our
let me go to the next slide there are
the building blocks our dna and rna
um actually as early as the 1950s we
have learned
to to interfere or interrupt
the the dna iron synthesis to treat
cancer
and this compound is oil here actually
made big difference
in in the survival rate of leukemia in
1950s
and with time we learned that
you can try to make analogs of this
natural building blocks
and food the virus to taking them in
taking these analogs to build their dna
rna in that sense
you can interrupt with a viral synthesis
a viral replication on the left i can
even show actually if we remove
the the three prime hydroxy group from
what i've shown from natural analog
natural nuclei size um we successfully
developed
commercial drugs to treat herpes simplex
hiv infection and hepatitis b
by the same principle you can also look
at
you can also you can look at um develop
antivirals against rna viruses and that
successful lead to sensible
successful discovery of drugs that
can um treat influenza and hepatitis c
and most recently the sars coronal virus
ii which is the the virus caused
covalent nitin
on the next slide i will show you at the
molecular level how these nucleus and
analogues work
so in this slide you can see actually i
give you example of an
example we're looking at the
hiv-infected cell
on the left part of the column on the
left part of the slide you'll see
two analogues so these are all adenosine
analogues and on the top
uh the tap is approved for hiv treatment
on the bottom it's not firm but we
actually the difference between this two
compounds they just have
you see the blue branches hang on the
right these we call products
so they can mask the charge when
brought by the phosphate and make this
compound 100 times more efficient taking
it by the cell
then turnout for itself which is shown
on the bottom
then once this tap or turnover
enters a cell the cell the hydrolysis
present in the cell will remove all the
branches now
you see um calf which has a
monophosphate on it
and then different
phosphor transferences again in our cell
will take care of adding one and two
phosphates
concentrate consecutively into this
molecule now we reach to a
a stage of the compound we call an
active metabolite
so when you talk about nucleoside
analogues actually
that species calendar cell is not the
truly active species
you have to reach this stage which will
be
used by the viral application and often
you'll hear the termite called
active metabolite and what happened from
this point on
the viral application machinery in this
particular case is hiv
hiv reverse transcriptase which is a
dna dependent rna sensitivity of rna
since rna polymerase or can be a dna
dependent dna polymerase
it will incorporate this analog into its
growing dna chain
but i illustrate on here with the red
dots
it can get incorporated but due to the
structure modification
there won't be incoming euclid head
attached to that
to allow um further elongation
and that hot um vital rna dna synthesis
and that's how it stopped the viral
replication
but at the same time you can imagine in
our human cell
viral replication won't be the same only
thing happening because
we also have our own dna and rna
replication machineries and the tricky
part is make sure we develop
a drug that is only used by the viral
polymerases and minimally used by our
host
of polymerases and that learn easy to
say but
very hard to achieve so on the next few
slides i'll share with you a few case
studies
of the painful failures we have
encountered over the past 40 years
um grades gratefully we learn from this
but let me share with this you the first
one is
fiau it's this compound
showed minimal toxicity in pre-clinical
animal species
and showed didn't show any toxins during
phase one
i'm only doing phase two that you can
see
um one patient developed liver toxicity
shock and lactic acidosis
i think for you guys who work with um
cellular respiration probably hope that
would
give you some hint and then the more
patient develop toxicity so
the clinical development stopped
because of this many groups that work on
this try to figure out
what the bottom line what the cause of
that this toxicity
what is off target for this compound
and um after many groups work together
we learned that mitochondria dna
polymerase
is a primary off target for this
compound
so we start to implement assay to
evaluate that look at look at
mitochondrial dna content
look at the incorporation and inhibition
of mitochondria dna polymerase
so we thought we solved this problem and
we can move forward
but then 20 years later when we
developed
hcv antiviral bear in mind the first
example i showed you earlier
we're treating with a dna virus but this
one we are treating rna virus now
and this compound again um
in phase 2 trial showed severe
toxicity in one patient this time it's
not liver toxicity it's not lactic acid
but it's heart and kidney
and the clinical trial stopped so we
look back
and it's kind of baffled to us because
the lessons we learned from the previous
one
didn't seem to help us because look at
mitochondrial dna
they didn't seem to touch mitochondria
dna
but actually the the following word from
my group
another group showed that in this
particular case is a mitochondrial iron
polymerase get
a hit what i show you is example here
but it's definitely not an isolated case
because i want to show you a landscape
um once a while i mean when we develop
hcv nucleus analogs
so you can see i have eight compounds
here and i'll show the fate
of them all of them entered phase one
i mean most of interface too and then
let's see what happened so only one
compound
sophosphere so phosphate ware um
get approved as an hcv and actually now
it's being used and
the the fact we can reach 99 pure
of the hcv patient really this compound
um
at a great low in the combination
against a cocktail treatment
but you can see the one in the blue they
are they fail due to
um inefficient pk but was shown on the
bottom
all the way circled in red they failed
due to toxicity
and you can see the toxins are quite
diverse from libra toxicity to
hematologic
to heart kidney and gi
so when we look at these different
toxicities that made us who
went back to look at the early hiv
antivirals
right even though we already know
mitochondrial toxicity mitochondria is
the target there but look at all the
plethora of different uh clinical
representations
heart you know neuropathy deafness
lactic
acid doses so um
at that time imagine you're in the 1980s
early 1990s look at this taxes and say
what is going on
um but someone really made a connection
here it's basically
made out to look at compare the
phenomenon we see
in nucleus and analog discovery in scene
clinic
to the inherited mitochondria
disease here you can see when you have a
mitochondrial mutation
or disease you can see there is a very
diverse toxicity when
you link to the right it seems to
they're connected um
actually i think that this is how it led
us through the mitochondrial
path uh when i talk to toxicologists
i say you know um we have all the ways
to monitor
toxicity in preclinical species
why we um it seems so hard and
he he told me that he would rather work
with a compound with general toxicity
because he said i can see them
in my preclinical models technical and
models but when you work with
mitochondria toxicity
is tough because it takes
chronic exposure and the symptoms often
delayed
and also there's rapid deterioration you
may not see
anything to one point um the note point
of return
we call the cliff effect and this being
have been observed
by many so now um to understand
this one i'd like to bring you to
mitochondria to understand
what is unique about mitochondria to
this group people of course
don't you remind mitochondria is so
important in our cell biology
but what's unique about it it has its
own dna
um so the dna also has own polymerase
but these polymerase
are less efficient than i guess they're
because they had more
relevant to bacterial origin it's less
sophisticated in terms of proofreading
and recognize the i guess the fake
nucleus size
um than our regular dna polymerase
replication machinery
and also there's mitochondria has
multiple
dna copies so in a sense that's where
the cliff effect comes from right in our
cell-based essay we found
we can deplete mitochondrial dna down to
15
and then the cell still survives you can
see the atp levels seem to be
normal but you have to reach a certain
point then
the the cell collapse so now look at
now i share with them about biology
unique biology of mitochondria
let's look at what are the conventional
ways we look at toxicity
for when we develop drug for therapy
often we have cellular system we have
animal models and we go to human subject
and hopefully we can stop a drug before
it's
come to this step but the cellular
system
for a long time will use cancer derived
cells and culture in high glucose media
and that kind of just makes the cancer
cells
probably doesn't need to rely a hundred
percent
on mitochondria at all because it has
sufficient nutrients going on there
and the second one is annual models
because purebred animals
may not reflect the diversity in
mitochondria
because many there is a portion of us
population
who had mitochondrial dysfunction but
may not be symptomatic
and only to stress the system enough to
see this one
so over the years learn from the failure
or learn from
the heart for the harmful or the
hurtful failure we learned so we
developed the system i've been testing
this system over the years
this is our the current screening
paradigm for this
class compounds in our group is
basically we use biochemical essay
to look at dna on a polymerases and see
whether this nucleus analog touch them
second one we look at the cellular level
and we use two type of cells both the
primary cells and immobilized cells and
we can learn different
information from them the lastly we go
to the mitochondrial level
look at the dna depletion
the particular mitochondrial protein
expression and last look at the
functional assay respiration
so now i'll go to each one and tell you
the parameters we look for
the first one is a biochemical essay the
biochemical essay will
try to answer two questions the first
one
is the analog it's a substrate for the
human enzymes
the second one is analog is the
inhibitor
and the two type of enzymes we look at
dna polymerases and rna polymerases
and also depend on the inhibitor we
study for example if we look at the
dna virus well more focused on this one
uh conversely if we look at rla
polymerase we were more focused
on this of target because we know
actually they have very
distinct all the viral polymers have
this distinct recognition for different
substrates
so on the next slide i'll give you
example that how
we study whether compound is a substrate
for in this particular case is
mitochondria are in polymerase
so on this gel on this slide i'll show
you we look at potential compound which
shown in the structure there is two
prime c
mesociting and um
on the right to the right to it you can
see i have a pre-annealed primer
template
these rna primer templates and
the primer is five prime labeled by um
p33 so when i run this
product or when i run this on my gel you
can see the gel shown on the bottom
of the slide with the arrow the far left
column
is my rna primer so you can consider
that my starting material
and then in the experiment i'm going to
put in
a next incoming analog of
which can be a natural ctp or ctp analog
you see on the right of my primer name
will be the ctp inc
result of cpp incorporation you can see
m plus band
so in a second if you can see the
disappearance of my rna primer
and appearance of a one band right above
it
that indicate that the human
mitochondrial rna polymerase
will use this uh cdp at the substrate
and to the right of my ctp lane you will
see four analogues
and in this particular case all for
these analogs
can be used by the mitochondria rna
polymerase
um of course if i'm a drug developer i
won't be very happy
very happy with this result because
ideally i don't want
human mitochondrial arms rna polymerase
we use this
but also it's a great way to tell me
that these compounds are shown here
high mitochondrial liability
now i'll move away from them biochemical
essay to tell you about
how do we monitor a general toxicity at
the cellular level
uh see in this particular one we look at
both the cell lines and the primary
cells
and this can study we often do from 14 5
to 14 days because
as i mentioned the medical toxicity can
be seen
chronic treatment and um the reason i
use both cell lines and primary cells
is is because in the cell lungs they're
fast replicating
cells and they are more a lot of times
they're more sensitive to the
mitochondrial toxicity actually fda
guidelines
when you develop this class of compounds
they ask you to use
um tests in fast replicating cells just
to see that the primary cells that
we have like to get tissue relevance you
can see i use liver
kidney blood and bone marrow
again when we use different nucleoside
products
due to the cellular enzymes you may see
different degree of activation
for different class different compounds
so that's why we use both
primary cells and cell lines and last
i'd like to
move to the mitochondria focused from
the previous slide you can see
what i can measure only the cc50
but the question is whether the compound
the general toxicity the general toxin
or is mitochondria toxin because again
you can tell these comp this
when the compound has different
properties will treat them differently
so now i go to mitochondria and the two
studies are focused on basically look at
mitochondrial protein expression
and mitochondria respiration which many
of you
may have started to look at
mitochondrial respiration
in your own lab let's go to look at the
monitoring mitochondrial protein
synthesis so in this one
i will treat the cells with compound for
a few days
five days and i'll light lyso cells in a
sense
um it's basically get a snapshot of the
mitochondrial protein expression
at certain after certain day of
treatment the reason i
i can't tell whether compound specific
mitochondria toxin actually is it's very
cool
because mitochondria as i've shown here
has
has its protein come from different
sources one is like cox-1
is as shown here is encoded by
mitochondria dna
so the protein is made right there
and but in mitochondria um a majority of
the enzyme not made
within mitochondria actually the
proteins are encoded by
nuclear dna so they're made and then
transported into mitochondria
so the last example is um succinate
dehydrogenase i
a so by comparing the the
expression level of these two proteins i
can tell you
whether a toxin is particularly
mitochondria
toxin and as shown on the next slide um
i showed side by side the the profile
if i have a general toxin for in this
case pyramiding
and it's quite different to
the one on the right with chlorofemipel
chlorine phenical
is uh specific inhibitor of
mitochondrial protein
synthesis and the three parameters i
monitor here
are colored in three different colors
the
the color in dotted red is atp
content which i monitor which i measured
in as parallel as a
um by cell tighter glow and which
colored in blue
that is the that's a protein encoded by
nuclear dna
and the green is a mitochondrial
specific encoded
protein cox one and you can see
for genotoxin everything comes down at
the same time
as a function of increasing drug
concentration but on the right you can
see among the three parameters the first
com stone it is a mitochondrial specific
protein expression
so so i i think this is a great to tell
us
when you typically will measure cell
cellular toxicity by using atp
but in this case you can see actually
the atp measurement is not the most
sensitive one because
way before atp comes down the
mitochondrial protein already
dropped as a result of drug treatment
now how do we use this assay to look at
nucleoside
antiviral in this particular case you
can focus your attention on the
right corner uh right bottom corner you
can see
uh the phrase little cytopine that's
actually one of the compounds that show
you
failed clinical phase one trial due to
hematologic toxicity
and you can see it's had very dissimilar
patterns as the specific quarantico
shown on the top so next i like to move
to
my one of my favorite um instrument
is monitor something can allow us to
monitor live cells
look at mitochondrial respiration
because mitochondrial function we
know you can have many ways to look at
it but really the oxygen consumption
real time is golden standard and in the
diatom to show you
later on really we monitor when i look
at when i tell you out of the rush
position parameter i
refer to one parameter that is measured
by the mitral stress test
um this particular case in our case i
figured out i refer to the spare
capacity
which difference between the maximum
respiration
and the spare respiration
with this i'd like to share with you the
data
so in this particular slide i share with
you uh we monitor
three parameters at the dose response
for for
different class of compounds the first
one we show in green
is dna content which we measured
after a sea horse instrument all the
measurement was done then we
take the place analyze the cells and
measure dna content
and the atp level is we basically set up
a parallel experiment from the seahorse
and that's used cell titan glow and the
the blue showing blue is spare
respiratory capacity which is measured
by the sea horse instrument i showed you
earlier
and in this particular case i'll show
you
we use three different compounds which
has there's unique way to inhibit
mitochondria
uh function but they all seem very
similar profile right the first one on
the
left
is it's a chlorine phenical inhibit
mitochondrial protein synthesis
and in the middle is ddc which inhibits
mitochondrial dna synthesis
and on the right is fluoridocitine which
inhibits
mitochondria rna synthesis is this and
you can see they all follow very similar
patterns um the atp level doesn't
at atp and dna level stay quite constant
almost to the i mean to the end of the
high at the highest concentration of the
drug treatment
however way before that you will see a
decrease of the mitochondrial
respiration of this case various
filtration capacity
so really seahorse instruments give us a
wonderful way to look into the the world
of
mitochondrial function and
give us a really early indication of
whether a compound regardless of their
maximum functions and mechanisms of
action
to tell us pay attention to this
compound because it does something to
decrease the mitochondrial function
and so before this slide i share with
you we can look at the mitochondrial
toxin through the mitochondria
protein expression now if i put them
side by side
as shown on this slide on the left is i
look at respiration
on the right i look at the mitochondrial
protein synthesis
and i can see they're associated right
because i'm testing the same compound
on the left i see disappearance of
mitochondrial respiration as functional
treatment on the right i see
the disappearance a lowered expression
of the the protein expression of
mitochondria so
so this is really give a lot of
confidence or comfort to saying this all
makes sense
now i share with you our screening
paradigm and with this same exact
screaming paradigm i'd like to
share with you um what we have found
when you look at um
ram deserver ramdas avir
for a long time we know it is um
it is the anti it is the nucleus analog
that is active against many
many viruses as shown on the right you
can see
um early on we know it is active against
ebola
margaret marburg mer stars so way before
the kobe 19 we know it's activity
um but it's it's hard to do clinic
trials against murders
or stars because they come and go and
when you look at this compound
on the left basically you can see that
it has
multiple branches but on the left part
of the molecule which is kind of colored
in
light orange these are they we call
these products right the mass of
phosphate
functional group and the the blue
functional group you can see
on the to the right of the molecule that
is where the modification
introduced to make it uh really active
against um
different viruses in this particular
panel
um so ram deserve as you know it has
been proved
uh to treat cova-19
but next i want to share with you as
researchers in the pre-clinical
branch how we evaluate the potential
liability of this compound
because you can you can you can see from
the early
painful lessons we learned we are very
careful about
how we are advanced so whether we'll
advance the nucleus and analog into
clinical trial
so first i'd like to go with a pre uh
i'll go with the biochemical evaluation
so the the the first question of course
we are asked
whether the active metabolite of ram
deserve
is a substrate and the inhibitor
of human dna armed human races
and on the top table you can see that we
use
look at the dna polymerase gamma and
mitochondria are in preliminary look at
the incorporation
and represent that the percentage of
natural ntp
and the result is actually rhomdus over
triphosphate
is a poor substrate for these host
polymerases which are great news
and the bottom table shows that if i
look at inhibition
of multiple dna and narrow polymerase in
this case they're
important alpha beta and gamma and rna
polymerase part
2 and mitochondrial polymerase
and you can see up to 200 micro molar
concentration
we see minimal inhibition and
indicating rabbit ramadasa very active
metabolites
weak inhibitor now i'll move to the
cellular level to look at the general
toxicity
so which um on this table i'll show you
the cc50 is again this is measured by
celtic glow by treating the cells
five to 14 days in cell culture
and under the cell column you can see i
have
both um cell lab adaptive cells these
are cancer cell lines also the primary
cells
and when you move to the right the
compounds i tested here
not just rheumatoid are which are shown
under rdv
but also there are the species that
main metabolite for ram deserve so that
is 4.1524
and then i used to the
cc factor value to calculate the the
selectivity index
basically the antiviral activity
used to divide
the specific value and the the
conclusions my 16 my selective index is
at least more than 170
that give us comfort um this this
compound
has a therapeutic window but knowing
this compound i mean when you look at
from that severe cc50 you may say well
these cc50s
are not that impressive they're under
for instance
they're under 10 micromolar but my
question i want to see if this compound
is a general toxin
i'll show toxicity um at the general
nature always
particularly mitochondria toxicity
because when you look at toxins you just
also bear in mind
the clinical exposure and also treatment
time so oh
bear this in mind um when you look at
really whether this toxicity will be
shown in clinic so let's come to the
the maximum study so this slide i show
you we'll look at the trigger cell to
look at the mitochondrial protein
expression
and on the right is i put a profile of a
positive control the chloramine phenical
what you will see with the specific
mitochondrotoxin and clearly
ramadan severe and this main metabolite
showed minimal mitochondria specific
toxicity in terms of mitochondrial
protein expression
now let's go look at the cellular
respiration measured by sea horse
instrument
and you can see here i use two primary
cells
the liver and kidney again in this case
i didn't see clear separation between
these three parameters
that indicating that rhamdosovir is not
a specific mitochondrial toxin and the
liability for for
mitochondrial toxicity is low
so with that i'd like to conclude that
hopefully by this time you are
convinced that acronyms and analogues
are cornerstones for antiviral
therapy and over the 40 years we learned
mitochondria is the potential of target
for this class compounds
and you should look at both
mitochondrial dna synthesis and
mitochondrial rna synthesis
for different antiviral classes when you
target the dna
mitochond and when you target the dna
virus or rna virus
and also we learned over the years that
we should use multiple approaches
to evaluate risk mitochondrial toxicity
and um cellular respiration really
has been a wonderful and very powerful
tool for us to
assessing mitochondrial liability
especially
when you do not know the precise of
target but just look at the functional
readout give us really good indication
where we should follow up next
and last i'd like to thank
all the people helped us along the way
um dr bison when we
has been such a wonderful mentor
collaborator when we um bought our first
singapore's
first seahorse instrument eight years
ago
we talked to him invited him to gilead
and he just has been such a warm
and wonderful collaborator to work with
and dr martin brennan and dr david
nichols
they are instrumental for us to
understand about energetics
um if you haven't been to the training
of the
bioenergetics at box institute i highly
recommend
you to go because i remember the first
year we went there
um so many things went all over my head
but then after working with seahorse
instrument for a few years we went back
again
and we have such deep deeper
appreciation of their knowledge
and i believe probably i should go back
one more time just to
take full advantage of their training
and doctor one wheel and fighter i
haven't met her in person but
i read all of her publications i still
remember
when i first tried to rally support to
buy
to buy our first seahorse instrument and
i printed out over papers
um and went to our vp and say
look at this look at what fighter had
done and i
got on my instrument so thank you dr
will i'd also like to thank my agilent
seahorse colleagues because when i look
at them
they first come to us as really
excellent scientists and wonderful
collaborators
and after that i mean buying instruments
and working with instruments
is it's just a natural course so thank
you all for
helping us along the way and of course
last but definitely not least
i'd like to thank my colleagues at
gillette sciences
uh early in my mind is the best horse
whisperer
in the world because all that you have
seen on the seahorse instrument
was done by her and
thank you ely for the partnership over
the past so many years
with this i welcome questions and
comments
thank you joy for a wonderful
presentation
that was very insightful of uh and to
provide us with an uh an outline of what
you and yearly
do in the lab in terms of toxicity we
will now start the question and answer
portion of the webinar
again if you have questions you'd like
to ask please type it into the q a box
we'll get try to get through as many
questions as we can
and if we don't get a chance to get
through your question we'll look forward
to join in the agilent team to follow
love after the conference now let's get
started
um so joy first question
is ha
um let's see do you
evaluate middle uh contour toxicity as a
primary screening for toxicity or a more
advanced screening and lead optimization
that's a great question um i'll say
the answer actually two parts so when we
have a nucleus and analog and when we
find it is
active against virus so the biochemical
essay
actually i'll call that the primary
essay but we will not do
and then we'll do this general cc50 but
the
the mitochondrial function the the
c-horse instrument won't way too much
later on so the primary acid the
biochemical is that i'll say primary but
still following after we find the
compound is active against the targeted
virus
by virus so not precisely primary but a
closed secondary for the biochemical one
but for the mitochondrial part i think
for the seahorse product will wait
probably the third step
thank you another question
um and this is a more specific question
for the spare respiratory capacity
on slide 33 that you presented what was
the incubation time of the cells with
the drugs chloro
cholargo coffino dvc and the other drugs
does the spare respiratory capacity
response
happen fast or slow
um okay so slide 33 right
i might get that right slide 33
okay um what's the question what's the
treatment time
yes right what is the incredible time of
the cells with the drug
okay so all these are uh three-day
treatment
so okay so actually that's a great
question in terms of time because
we we did look at let me give you
example of dvc
um so for for this particular compound
we did look at the
the the signal of the the phenotype and
the function time
and we found for for ddc in particular
day one you won't see you won't see full
decrease of the
respiration but by day five that the
curve starts to merge together
so the sweet spot is state three for ddc
and then for for the for for little
siding as well so we
we said three-day treatment is it's good
enough
but let me try to remember it for
qualifical have we done
a similar time course study
i'll at this point i'll say no so that
doesn't answer the question
the the portion of the time uh portion
and what's the other i think there's
another
question in that question justin you can
remind me
the oh it's just mostly a time course uh
the data
presented in terms of the spare capacity
i guess um the
the uh user wanted to understand how
long you treat it with the drugs
three days i think yes okay thank you
yeah no problem uh another question
um you sh you show that atp level
in some of the slides that you presented
doesn't change but
there's a decrease in respiratory
capacity
is it due to a compensation through
increase in glycolysis
due to cell culture
that's what we believe so too actually
we have we can see that i think india
had that showing that
um increased glycolysis yes precisely i
agree that the cell has a way to
compensate for a shorter period of time
but yeah i can't really if you can still
see my slide which is like 33
it is if i look at this so this time
from this snapshot you're looking at day
three but when i go to date five
everything will come down so in the
sense the cell cannot go on forever
uh so by that time you'll see the atp
line which in red will come down as well
yes okay um
and here's another great question has
any animal study
been done looking at redemption
their toxicity yeah yes
yes um that has been done definitely but
it's it's again it's a it's a
therapeutic
treat uh window uh because when you look
at the i believe in
any and type in any therapy i think it's
really hard to find
compounds just absolutely have no toxins
at all but it's really the the window
and it's also related to the treatment
duration
because um right the pure treatment
duration for for
hobby 19 is a five to ten day treatment
it's we're treating acute virus
so to answer the question yes we have
seen toxicity in pregnant species
but there is enough window to encourage
us to move forward
okay uh another question
is there any other possible mechanism
by which an antiviral uh drug the
nucleus site analogs
cause mitochondria dysfunction other
than the mitochondria gene expression or
mitochondria
dna replication excellent question
yes i'm so glad you point this out
because it's true
i mean my mitochondrial toxicity
the the gene level the protein level is
definitely not the one and only
a potential one for example i'll give
you a rough
ram c rubber baron that is
known to be a mutagen and also it
affects the
the ntp or dntp pools so the pools of
nucleoside
natural nucleoside in that sense it can
it can
decrease that and then through that way
it will affect
the cellular function and also for azt
it's very old
hiv antiviral people
study this for the longest time try to
see whether it's inhibited mitochondria
implements actually it is not
oh as relatively less extent to the fact
it's in fact um again medical
effect nucleoside nucleotide metabolism
um the other factor
so doesn't it affect my mitochondrial
function but
not through the ways i described today
so
thank you so much for bringing that
point yes there are other mechanisms it
can
eventually affect mitochondria but not
through the ones i mentioned
thank you sure
uh another question um why
does different mitotoxin compound
show variation in organ or tissue
failure
for example cardiotoxicity but with
liver toxicity
and related to this question do we need
to use different
tissue specific cell type for the
mitochondria
systems tests
that's excellent question as well and
i've been thinking that for a long time
um let me go to
i think our one on the slide so so the
the question yes
i mean when we look at this like why
um i it's due to i believe for
for example why sometimes we see liver
and sometimes we will see heart
um i i think it's really due to just pk
that pharmacokinetic is an accumulation
of the compound for for this particular
one i mean
when we look at this one because the
drug they are the drug i show you at the
bottom slide they are designed to be
retargeting so i'm not quite surprised
when you see liver toxicity because
the concentration of this compound is
supposed to be higher liver
but in this particular case why is you
know why
go to heart i guess in
in a short way i say we don't know but
also on the
on the alternatively we can also tell
you that
um when people measure the active
metabolite
in heart the local concentration
is high enough to cause this damage
um yes so that i can tell you
um oh the other question when whether we
look at the leaf of tissue specific
cells we have done that and the result
is not very helpful in the sense
when we treat the cells we've shown
particular
kidney toxins in kidney cells and
compared to other
organ derived cells we didn't that
didn't give us really good correlation
so i i that's why i feel
it's not that straightforward that's why
i feel the multiple layers of toxicity
of multiple layers of screening helpful
and
also for example if you come to me and
say joy
i you you know this compound you show to
your c
horse that you've shown to you about
chemical essay you show there's a
mitochondrial toxin then can you
predict if we put in a human i hope not
but if you put in human what kind of
toxicity will you see
and i cannot uh that that's a mystery so
i hope
that probably we can work together to um
advance this as well but
to answer your question it's very hard
to predict which target which
tissue will hit um
totally understand and um along those
lines
um have you thought about using
um you know there's in terms of the the
stem cell
world where um in 2006
uh the ability to form more of like
human induced poly potent stem cells
as a way to mimic more of a particular
physiologically relevant model to look
at for example toxicity
or cardiotoxicity liver toxicity
as a a tool that you may
use um to to to be more specific i think
um of course it's hard to get specific
cells from
from humans or animal but using more
like human human-derived um poly-potent
stem cells
i think as a model i definitely that i
definitely think that the possibility
especially help help us to understand
for example we
went to practical animal species and
funds certain specific tissue
related one and it's great to know that
as well and there's good to know
ahead of time as well but the question
is how how extensive do you go but i
i if people have ideas i welcome we can
collaborate we can look into this
together
okay great um and then one last question
uh before we end um did you compare
cellular respiratory results with other
mitochondria toxicity assay
like glue glucose and galactose or
mitochondria membrane potential
we didn't look at the mitochondria
potential when there's a diabetes essay
because i felt
it's um it's inferior than the the
seahorse
instrument but actually we we have done
the galactose and glucose
um assay and uh so in a sense in that
case when you
so in theory i mean when you have
galactose adaptive cells because they
cannot
switch to the glucose pathway so they
will be more vulnerable to a
mitochondrial toxin
and it's it's a great in principle but
when you look at first of all
as far as i know i mean the the the
poster child of the mitochondrial toxin
for example bbc
the early drug discovery bbc and um
other mitochondria toxins have been
shown
positive in that particular assay um so
i would say
that assay may work great for other
classes compound for nucleoside
nucleotides
we haven't found a really nice
correlation at the predictive
as a parameter
okay thank you again joy for sharing
your work with us today and thank you
to our audience for your questions and
participation
now if you like to continue a question
and discussion with joy
join us now in our network lounge by
clicking the link to the networking
lounge
that populates at the close of the
webinar